suivent du bifteck de contre filet à
moitié prix c'est le genre d'aliments
proche d'être périmés ou en surplus
d'inventaire qui se retrouvent sur
l'application flash food depuis le mois
de février une dizaine de clients
profitent chaque jour de ces aubaines en
un simple clic
avant de se rendre au maxi joker pour
récupérer leurs achats la viande c'est
vraiment que tu chauffes la moitié donc
si j'achète 30 $ non non ça me coûterait
60 et que ça vaut vraiment la peine
puis-je a fait geler donc même si elle
est bonne en trois jours ça change
absolue marie vous ont fait le tour du
créateur le matin l'après-midi et le
soir donc pour retourner par jour donc
c'est à ces moments alors que lors du
tri qu'on met les produits dans les
dents le flashmob généralement suit 50
fonctions mais si nous le marchand qui
décide quel pourcentage pour une après
avoir été testé dans des supermarchés
québécois le programme qui s'attaque au
gaspillage alimentaire s'élargit
maintenant à tous les maxi de la
province et à certains provigo c'est
dans la philosophie de la mission de
l'entreprise de réduire le gaspillage le
plus possible l'empreinte écologique qui
est très importante au niveau de la
bannière ce sont des produits qui sont
encore consommable ya aucun problème
d'intoxication mais aussi des petites
habitudes chez nous aussi qu'on essaye
de faire attention
je pense que ça commence par des petites
choses comme seuls des sacs de fruits et
légumes de 5 kg pour 5 dollars des
produits laitiers du pain du jus ou des
charcuteries depuis la fin février
mélanie quelques l'avoir économiser au
moins 100 dollars en ayant recours à
cette application une à deux fois par
semaine sur génial hein ça me fait quand
même des aliments que je normalement
j'achèterai l'impôt mais
l'ayant à moitié prix j'en profite pour
les essayer ce afin d'employer moi même
le débours avait donc des fois
effectivement c'est des produits qui
valent la peine
les épiceries continue aussi de proposer
des rabais de dernière minute de 30 ou
50 % en magasin pour effectuer des
ventes rapides les produits qui ne
trouve pas preneur sont remis aux
banques alimentaires est si précis la
flamande on la lance et radio canada
saguenay